Mashallah
Islam
Doctor of Islam The brother is an atheist and he says if you can answer the question he wants to say the
Shahada today
[music]
line
or
the brother saying that he is an atheist and he is ready to say the Shahada if you can
answer the
question and the question is can you find a
mistake in the Tripitaka Buddhist
Scripture which is wrong there
and mistake
brother
I normally give the question he is an atheist
and he would accept Islam if answer the question he can
you take out a single
mistake in the Buddhist Scripture so he is an
atheist then why is he talking about
Buddhist Scripture the first question anyway I am not here
to take out
mistakes in the Scripture but because you ask
me the major philosophy of Buddhism is
based on the four great truths do you have heard about
the four great  Truths of Buddha
Do You Know About the Four Great Truths of
Buddhism
Buddha He Does Know If You Don't Know They What You Know About
Buddha
Scripture If Someone Says I Know the Quran Do You Know I Don't Know
Surah Fatiha Don't Know So How Will
You Understand My Answer Then?  The
Basics of Buddhism Are the Four Great
Suits of Buddha?  If you don't know about it?   How will
you understand my answer?
Do you know the four great suits of Buddha?
Now he wants to know what are the four truths
about Buddhism.
But what do you know is right and wrong if you don't know
?  Anyway I wouldn't like to see you.
Wants to Know the Error in the Book Tripitaka
Tripitaka Is One of the Books of the
Buddhist Scriptures Buddha Scriptures
Are Dhamma Padda Many Things Are There But I'm
Going on the Basics Better Basics Now
According to What Buddha Said That There Were
Four Great Truths Number One There Is Sorrow
and Misery in the World Number One There Is
Sorrow and Misery in the World Truth Number Two
The cause of sorrow and misery is desire.
Number Three To Remove Sorrow and Miry You Have
To Remove Desire.
Number Four To Remove Desire You Have To Follow
The 10th Fold Path.
I am repeating.  Buddha Said The First
True Truth Is There Is Sorrow And Mirry In
This World.
Number to the Cause of Sorrow and Merry Desire.
You can remove So and Miri.  Number three by
removing desire.  Number four you have to follow
the eight fold part to remove desire.
[Music]
In the book
hey brother when I am doing higher things I don't go lower this is
much higher I am talking about higher things
I study the higher books
not the lower book these books are much higher if he doesn't know about
Buddhism then what can I
talk
so I am giving you the fault in the main
pillars of Buddhism my question is the
third
great truth of Buddha that to remove sorrow
and sorrow you have to remove desire.
Number four is you should follow the 10 fold part
to remove desire.  The Question Is If I Have
To Follow The 10 Fold Part I Have To Have A
Desire To Follow The 10 Fold Part.  So it says
you have to ever have a desire to remove desire.
It's contradicting logically.  Do you
understand?
The Third Gate Truth is There is the Cause of
Sorrow and Misery Desire Truth number three to
remove desire you have to remove misery number
four is you have to follow the 10 fold part
to remove desire that means you have to have the
desire to follow the 10 fold part to follow the 10
fold part so it says you should have a
desire to remove desire
so it's contradicting logically
so there for the man it's like house of
cards
it's contradicting.  How can you have a
desire to remove desire?  So that's the reason
and you can hear my other video cassettes.
I spoke on Buddhism.  Correct but I
mainly deal with the top once not the bottom
levels.  I am talking about the Main Dhamma
Padda and the other scriptures.  Hope the answer
the question.
Shanti De Shanti Devi in ​​India She is
reincarnated so he asking for your input
there is a Shanti Devi in ​​India there are many
Shanti Devis in India
she has reincarnated this is a philosophy of
Hinduism but its illogical and
unscientific.
Because once you die, you can't get rid of it
scientifically.  This is just a
hypothesis.  It's not proven scientifically
at all.  And even in Vedas when it talks about
reincarnation.
Punaram means next birth means life.  Even
Islam believes in reincarnation.  Next
life.  That means you come in this world,
next life you are rejected.  But there is no
life death life death cycle.  This is a
myth.  So even in Vedas when it talks about
reincarnation it is talking about next life which we
believe you go to heaven and hell but doesn't
believe in you become
a human being and come back and you become again
you come back.  This is just an
hypothesis which is unscientific.  Hope the
answer the question.
Man Bhumi
Fasla
Ok
Bhumi He
Asking About The Verse In Surah Fasla Ayat
Number N The Creation Of The Earth And The Heaven Is There
A Contradiction
The Refer Into The Verse Of Surah Fasla Chapter
41 Ayat Number N Which Talks About The Creation
Of The Heaven And The Earth And Asking Is There A
Contradiction.
There is an apparent contradiction,
apparent.  If you are not logical, you may think there is
a contradiction.  The Quranic Verse
of Surah Fuzaila Chapter 41 Number Nine says
that Allah has created the Heavens and the
Earth.
He created the heavens in two days.
He created the heavens on two days.
And He created it so that He
created the earth in two days and it starts
in two days and created the
mountains and placed it on the earth with it in
four days and created the heavens
in two days and He told it to come together willingly and
unwillingly and they said we come in
willing obedience verse number 11 So the
question is when Allah says He created
the earth in two days and the mountains standing
firm on it with the vegetation in four days and
He created the heavens in two days.
So here if you say two plus four plus two it sounds
like eight and many other places in
the Quran Allah says Allah created the heavens then the earth
in six days.  So there are
some critics of Islam who say it takes
two, four, two, eight days, many other places.
Allah has created the heaven and the six
dimensions in six days. So there is a
contradiction if you
read
the verses of the Quran
in Surah Fusila.
Chapter number 49 41. Verse number 10 11. It says we
created the earth in two days and
the earth along with the mountains in four
days. Summa heaven in two days. Now summa in
Arabic has two meanings. It can either mean and
or it can mean simultaneously.
So if I tell you I want to make a
building I
own and the building I want to
make in six days
I give the breakup
six months.  I want to make the building
in six months.  I make the compound in 2
months.
I Make the Basement in 2 Months and I Make the
20 Story Building in Four Months.  Hey you
told six months.  It is four months.
Compound in 2 months, basement in 2 months.
When I'm making the compound, I'm
making the basement simultaneously.  So when
I'm making 2 Months the Compound I'm making
The Basement also in 2 months.  So compound
and the basement make in 2 months.  Then the
balance 20 fl oz I make in four months.  So how
much is the total?
Six months not eight months.  So similarly when
Allah says he made the earth and the
mountains standing firm on it.  Earth Two
Months Mountain Standing Four Months Six
Months.  Summa, while this was
happening, you also met the sky.  So,
actually it is six months only.  There is
not a single contradiction anywhere in the
Quran.  Allah says in the Quran Sura Nisa
Chapter Four Verse Number 82 Aladd
Quran.  Do they not consider the Quran vi ke
ala Quran wala
ladaf kasira?   Do they
not consider the Quran when they have not been
contradictions? There have been many
contradictions. So Quran
says there is not a single contradiction in the Quran. There is
not a single mistake in the
Quran. Hope the answer is the question. Now will you say
the prince. Will you say
the prince.
Time is up. The police is saying wait
wait police this is seeing time is up.
Yes, I'm sure.
Wait, listen to me, listen to me.
Yes, he was to Shahada.
Okay, Mashallah.
Can I take the Shahada, I am asking the police,
can I take the Sharada?  No, hand the Muslim
police, can I take or not?  Brother police
man?
Can I take Shada or not?  2 minutes.
Allah will give you Sawab.  Why You Want to
Stop the Non-Muslim from Becoming
Muslim.  Allah will give you Sawab.   If Allah wills it.
In India they allow me 12 o
clock 2 o clock When in Indonesia 11 o
clock Do you agree there
is one God
Abu Sharis Translate Yes Aaya
Parchaya Tu Hani Tu Satu Yes I
believe this one Do
you believe that Prophet Mohammad is a
messenger of God
Yes Ya Parchaya Yes He
Believe Do you want to
accept Islam
Ya Parchaya
is forcing anyone to accept Islam
Accept
No Are
you doing it on freelancing
Become Muslim
Islam
No one giving money but half is Muslim and he has been
listening to many videos
including
Mashallah Mashallah Inshalah I will say that
in Arabic You can repeat it Ashad Ashad
Allah Allah ilaha ilaha illallah illallah
wa Ashad Ashad Anna Anna
Mohammadan
Abdu
wa Rasool
I be witness I be
witness That there is no
God That there
is no God
But Allah
and I bear witness
and witness that
Prophet Mohammad
is the Messenger
and servant
of Allah
Mashallah Muslim
Takbir
Allahu Akbar
Akbar
and I pray to Allah Subhana Taala that all your
previous are forgiven may Allah give you
the best in this world and Akhirah may
Allah guide you to get your friends and
your family to Islam Inshalah